HIMSELF.
HIS MEDIA BLITZ IS IN FULL
SWING, AND IT IS NOT GOING WELL
FOR HIM.
WE WILL EXPLAIN IN TONIGHT'S
OPENING MONOLOGUE.
ALL RIGHT, WE START TONIGHT WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP SHOOTING DOWN A
WHILE THE LIBERAL MEDIA
SPECULATION AS ALWAYS.
BUT HE IS GOING TO FIRE ROBERT
MUELLER AND ROD ROSENSTEIN.
DURING THE PRESS CONFERENCE,
THIS IS WHAT HE HAD TO SAY.
>> WE ARE HOPEFULLY COMING TO
THE END.
IT IS A BAD THING FOR OUR
COUNTRY.
VERY, BAD THING FOR OUR COUNTRY.
BUT THERE HAS BEEN NO COLLUSION,
THEY WON'T FIND ANY COLLISION,
IT DOESN'T EXIST.
AS FAR AS THE TWO GENTLEMEN WHO
TOLD ME ABOUT IT, THEY HAVE BEEN
SAYING I'M GOING TO GET RID OF
THEM FOR THE LAST THREE MONTHS.
FOUR MONTHS.
FIVE MONTHS.
AND THEY ARE STILL HERE.
SO WE WANT TO GET THE
INVESTIGATION OVER WITH, DONE
WITH, PUT IT BEHIND US.
>> Sean: MAYBE THAT WILL
FINALLY PUT LIBERAL RUMORS TO
REST.
IT NOW, ALSO TONIGHT, WE HAVE A
DIRECT MESSAGE TO THE TRUMPET
MEDIA.
WE KNOW YOU ARE WATCHING.
WHILE YOU HAVE BEEN PUSHING YOUR
CRACK FRAUD CONSPIRACY THEORIES
AROUND THE CLOCK 24/7, FOR OVER
A YEAR, WITHOUT ANY FACTS,
WE HAVE BEEN UNCOVERING ACTUAL
EVIDENCE AND WHAT IS NOW THE
BIGGEST ABUSE OF POWER SCANDAL
IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
NOW, THE MEDIA HAS BEEN LYING TO
YOU AND MISS LEADING YOU, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, BUT THEIR TIME
IS UP.
NOW, IF YOU REMEMBER BACK IN
JANUARY, WHEN I CAME BACK FROM
VACATION, I SAID 20 TEENS WOULD
BE THE YEAR OF THE BOOMERANG.
AND THAT ALL OF THESE SCANDALS
WERE GOING TO SWING BACK AND
BLOW UP RIGHT AND THE DEMOCRATS
AND THE MEDIA SPACES, AND THAT
IS EXACTLY WHAT IS HAPPENING
BECAUSE THERE ARE STUNNING NEW
DEVELOPMENTS JUST A TONIGHT.
TEN OTHER MEMBERS OF CONGRESS,
THEY HAVE SENT A CRIMINAL
REFERRAL LETTER TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL, JEFF SESSIONS,
THE FBI DIRECTOR, CHRISTOPHER
WRAY, IN THE U.S. ATTORNEY, JOHN
HOOVER.
AND THESE MEMBERS ARE NOW -- OF
CONGRESS, THEY ARE CALLING FOR
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATIONS INTO THE
POTENTIALLY ILLEGAL ACTIONS OF
JAMES COMEY, OF HILLARY CLINTON,
OF A LORETTA LYNCH, ANDREW
McCABE, PETER STRZOK, LISA
PAGE, AND OTHER OFFICIALS WHO
HAVE TIES TO THE UNVERIFIED
DOSSIER.
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS.
LET'S START WITH JAMES COMEY.
A QUICK SIDEBAR BEFORE WE LAY
OUT THE CASE AGAINST HIM.
WE HAVE BEEN A WARNING THAT THE
SELF-SERVING HOLIER-THAN-THOU
FBI DIRECTOR THAT HE HAS THE
RIGHT TO REMAIN SILENT, BUT HE
JUST CAN'T SEEM TO KEEP HIS
MOUTH SHUT.
AND IT HAS BEEN AMAZING TO ME
THAT COMEY DOESN'T HAVE AN ARMY
OF LAWYERS THAT HAVE BEEN
TELLING HIM TO KEEP QUIET AND
NOT TO RELEASE THIS BECAUSE HE
IS NOW TONIGHT FACING SERIOUS
LEGAL EXPOSURE.
HERE IS WHAT WE MEAN.
IN HIS BRAND-NEW LETTER, THESE
11 MEMBERS OF CONGRESS, THEY
HIGHLIGHT HOW HE SPENT
14 MINUTES BACK ON JULY 5TH 2016
LAYING OUT THE CASE FOR CRIMINAL
PROSECUTION AGAINST
HILLARY CLINTON, BUT THEN AT THE
VERY END, IT BASICALLY SAID
NEVER MIND AND DID NOT RECOMMEND
THE CRIMINAL CHARGES.
WE TALKED ABOUT EQUAL JUSTICE
UNDER THE LAW.
WE CANNOT HAVE A DUAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
NOW, WE HAVE SINCE FOUND OUT
THAT CALL ME AND STRZOK, AND
THEIR COHORTS, THEY SAVED
HILLARY CLINTON BY REACHING A
DECISION NOT TO PROSECUTE BEFORE
INTERVIEWING HILLARY CLINTON AND
A 17 OTHER KEY WITNESSES.
THEY WROTE THAT MONTHS BEFORE
THEY INTERVIEWED HER.
NOW, THIS INEXCUSABLE ABSURDITY.
THE LETTER TODAY ELSEWHERE THIS.
CHARGES AGAINST CLINTON SMITH
CONDUCTS THE JUST AND PROPER
INVESTIGATIVE CONDUCT.
POTENTIALLY MOTIVATED BY A
POLITICAL AGENDA.
AND BECAUSE OF THE OUTCOME OF
THESE CONGRESSMEN ARE NOW
REFERRING OBSTRUCTION OF
PROCEEDINGS BEFORE DEPARTMENTS,
AGENCIES, AND COMMITTEES.
AND 18 U.S. CODE, DEFINITIONS
FOR CERTAIN PROVISIONS, WHICH
APPEARS TO BE REFERRING TO
MAKING MISLEADING STATEMENTS.
AND THERE IS THE ISSUE OF HIS
MEMOS.
AN OUTCOME OF THIS LETTER
EXPLAINS THAT IN ORDER FOR
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS TO VIEW
THEM, THEY HAD TO GO TO A SECURE
FACILITY BECAUSE FOUR OF THE
SEVEN MEMOS WERE MORE CLASSIFIED
ADS OF SECRET AND CONFIDENTIAL
LEVELS.
WELL, WE ALSO HAVE THE ISSUE OF
COMEY AND WHAT HE DID.
HERE IS WHAT HE SAID BACK IN
JUNE UNDER OATH.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I ASKED -- THE PRESIDENT
TWEETED ON FRIDAY, AFTER I GOT
FIRED, THAT I BETTER HOPE THERE
ARE NOT TO TAPES.
I WOKE UP IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT ON MONDAY NIGHT BECAUSE IT
DID NOT SAVE ON ME, THAT THERE
MIGHT BE CORROBORATION FOR OUR
CONVERSATION.
THERE MIGHT BE A TABLE.
AND MY JUDGMENT WAS THAT I NEED
TO GET THAT END INTO THE PUBLIC
SQUARE.
SO I DID NOT DO IT MYSELF FOR A
VARIETY OF REASONS, BUT I ASKED
HIM TO BECAUSE I THOUGHT THAT
MIGHT PROMPT THE APPOINTMENT OF
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL.
>> Sean: HE JUST ADMITTED TO
LEAKING CLASSIFIED GOVERNMENT
INFORMATION.
LAWS AND CRIMES THAT APPLY.
LOOK AT THIS.
PUBLIC MONEY, PROPERTY, OR
RECORDS, THIS DEALS WITH
REMOVING THOSE GOVERNMENT MEMOS
FROM THE FBI.
THEN THERE IS 18 U.S. CODE 793.
WE TALK ABOUT THIS A LOT.
GATHERING, TRANSMITTING, OR
LOSING DEFENSE INFORMATION.
1924, UNAUTHORIZED REMOVAL AND
RETENTION OF CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS, OR MATERIAL.
ALL OF THIS SPELLS A MASSIVE
LEGAL TROUBLE TONIGHT FOR JAMES
COMEY, BUT IT IS JUST THE
BEGINNING OF COMEY'S POTENTIAL
CRIMINAL MISCONDUCT.
NOW, HE WROTE THE CLINTON
EXONERATION STATEMENT BEFORE THE
INVESTIGATION.
THAT MEANS BEFORE INTERVIEWING
HILLARY AND 17 OTHER KEY
WITNESSES.
THAT IS NOT WHAT HE TESTIFIED TO
UNDER OATH.
WE HAVE THE VIDEOTAPE YOU TAKE A
LOOK.
>> DIRECTOR, DID YOU MAKE THE
DECISION NOT TO RECOMMEND THAT
CHARGES BEFORE OR AFTER
HILLARY CLINTON WAS INTERVIEWED
BY THE FBI ON JULY THE SECOND?
>> AFTER.
COLLEAGUES OF OURS BELIEVE THAT
I AM LYING ABOUT WHEN I MADE
THIS DECISION, PLEASE URGE THEM
TO CONTACT ME PRIVATELY SO THAT
WE CAN HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT
THIS.
ALL I CAN DO IS TELL YOU THAT I
DID NOT KNOW WHAT WAS GOING TO
HAPPEN IN THAT INTERVIEW.
MAYBE SHE LIED IN A WAY THAT WE
CAN PROVE.
>> Sean: OKAY, THEY
INTERVIEWED HER IN JULY, HE
WROTE IT IN MAY.
NOW, THESE MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
ALSO POINT OUT THAT THERE
APPEARS TO BE MATERIAL
INCONSISTENCIES BETWEEN HIS
CONGRESSIONAL BRIEFING ON THE
FBI'S RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
AUTHOR, CHRISTOPHER STEELE, AND
THE DOJ DOCUMENTS THAT WERE
PROVIDED TO CONGRESS AFTERWARDS.
IT NOW, HERE ARE THE CRIMINAL
CHARGES THAT WOULD APPLY TO ME
IN THAT CASE.
CODE 1621.
PERJURY, GENERALLY, 1,001.
NOW, INSTEAD OF SITTING DOWN
WITH THE LIBERAL MEDIA, YOU
KNOW, THE DREAM TEAM OF LIBERALS
KNOW, THE DREAM TEAM OF LIBERAL
LIBERALS, GEORGE STEPHANOPOULOS,
THE LADIES OF THE "THE VIEW," HE
PROBABLY SHOULD BE LAWYERING UP.
ALSO RECOMMENDING CRIMINAL
CHARGES AGAINST HILLARY CLINTON.
AND AN INVESTIGATION.
IT NOW, WE KNOW SHE BROKE THE
LAW BY USING THAT UNSECURED
PRIVATE EMAIL SERVER AND A MOM
AND POP SHOP A BATHROOM CLOSET,
THEN DELETING 33,000 SUBPOENAED
EMAILS AND BEATING UP HER
DEVICES WITH THE HARD DRIVE.
THESE LAWMAKERS TODAY ARE NOW
DEMANDING AN INVESTIGATION INTO
CLINTON FOR HIDING PAYMENTS FOR
FUSION GPS FROM THE FEDERAL
COMMITTEE.
IT NOW THEY FUMBLED OVER TEN TO
$12 MILLION.
AND THEN THEY PAID FUSION GPS.
REMEMBER, FOREIGN NATIONALS ARE
NOT SUPPOSED TO INFLUENCE OUR
ELECTIONS.
ASK AT CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
HE THEN PUTS TOGETHER A DOSSIER,
FULL OF RUSSIAN LIES THAT WERE
NEVER VERIFIED.
NOW, THE READER, THE FORMER
ATTORNEY GENERAL, LORETTA LYNCH.
SHE HAS ISSUES TONIGHT.
THESE MEMBERS OF CONGRESS, THEY
WANT THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
NOW TO INVESTIGATE ALLEGATIONS
THAT LORETTA LYNCH THREATENED
THE FBI INFORMANT WITH REPRISAL.
REMEMBER, HE WAS ON THE SHOW.
THIS IS THE INFORMANT WENT
UNDERCOVER FOR YEARS AND EXPOSED
THE EXTORTION, RACKETEERING
SCHEME THAT WAS USED TO GET A
FOOTHOLD ON AMERICA'S URANIUM
MARKET.
ANDREW McCABE, HE IS ALSO
MENTIONED IN THIS CRIMINAL
REFERRAL LETTER.
THE REASON DOJ REPORT FOUND THAT
McCABE LIED UNDER OATH THREE
TIMES ABOUT LEAKING TO THE NEWS
MEDIA.
IT NOW, THOSE ARE SERIOUS
VIOLATIONS THAT INVOLVE AT LEAST
THREE CRIMINAL STATUTES, AND OF
COURSE, THESE LAWMAKERS WANT
McCABE INVESTIGATED.
ON TOP OF THAT, WE HAVE PETER
STRZOK AND LISA PAGE.
THEY ARE ALSO BEING REFERRED FOR
POSSIBLE CRIMINAL CHARGES
TONIGHT.
AN OUTCOME OF THE LETTER LAYS
OUT HOW TEXT MESSAGES SHOW THAT
STRZOK REMOVED A REFERENCE --
REMEMBER THE EXONERATION
STATEMENT, SHE WAS EMAILING WITH
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA.
THEY WITHDREW IT.
THEY TOOK IT OUT.
THEY WIPED IT OUT, WHICH MEANS
THAT OBAMA KNEW ABOUT THE SERVER
ALL ALONG.
THEY CHANGED IT THROUGH A
GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL.
SURE, THAT IS WHAT WE WILL CALL
PRESIDENT OBAMA.
THESE LAWMAKERS ARE ALSO CALLING
FOR MEMBERS TO BE INVESTIGATED
FOR LYING TO FEDERAL JUDGES.
WE HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS,
AS ONE OF THE BIGGEST
REVELATIONS.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE UNVERIFIED,
UNCORROBORATED, CLINTON BOUGHT
AND PAID FOR, PHONY RUSSIAN
PROPAGANDA DOSSIER, THEY USE
THAT IN ORDER TO GET A WARRANT
ASSOCIATE.
THAT IS LYING TO A JUDGE.
AND THEY NEVER TOLD THE JUDGE
THAT THEY PAID FOR IT, EITHER.
THESE ARE ALL MAJOR DEVELOPMENTS
TONIGHT.
AND ALL THESE BAD ACTORS THAT WE
HAVE NOW BEEN EXPOSING FOR OVER
A YEAR, I'M FEELING THAT ONION,
DAY BY DAY, WELL, NOW TODAY,
CRIMINAL REFERRALS HAVE BEEN
MADE TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
FINALLY.
AN OUTCOME OF THE BIG QUESTION
IS WHAT WILL THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL, JEFF
SESSIONS, WHAT WILL HE DO
TONIGHT?
WILL HE DEFEND THE CONSTITUTION?
EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER THE LAW, AND
THAT BIG STORY, BY THE WAY, IS
ONLY ONE OF OUR BREAKING NEWS OR
IS TONIGHT.
HOUSE OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN, HE IS ASKING THE DOJ
AND THE FBI, AND THE INSPECTOR